Well, good evening.
Why do I always have to say good evening
twice? Because the first time you don't say good evening back good
evening.
Thank you. I'm glad you guys are here. This is going to be a very very special night.
If you're a guest with us, and this is
your first time to attend. We would love to have a
Record of your visit and we've I like
to say that it's not an accident that you've joined us tonight that we pray that
you're here. So you're an answer to our prayers. And so there is
a QR code on that seat back right in front
of you and if you'll just click a picture of that then it'll take you to a website where
you can fill out a form because we'd love to have a record of your visit. I
want to share with you that this is the third of
four weeks where we will be looking at topics that
are very popular popular and well
discussed in the culture and next week.
We'll be our final week. We will look very briefly at two
things. We're going to look at climate change
and our response to that as biblical
stewards, but we're also going to talk about a
very practical way for us as Disciples
of Jesus Christ to respond to someone who may
disagree with us. We've talked about different issues
and but sometimes when we talk
about those issues, we've not discussed. Okay, how do I conduct
myself in the Bible is very
Clear how a believer in Jesus Christ should have a conversation
and we have an apologetic
and we can promote and provide
that apologetic. But how do we do it in a manner
that is most like Christ. And so we'll talk about that next week this week.
We're discussing a religious liberty and I
want to start off by saying that you have
to have crawled under a rock for a long
period of time not to have identified the fact that the
culture concerning religious liberty seems
to be shifting.
And it's shifting with such a
huge extent and
with such a great velocity that it looks
like that Christianity that Believers in
Jesus are headed toward a head-on
collision with the culture. And so these
are two completely different World Views and
we have to discuss. How do we
respond? If in fact the progressive liberal
agenda becomes the
prevailing moral agenda for my whole
life and for all of our Lives the judeo-christian moral
ethic has been the predominant or the prevailing
culture and that seems to be shifting. It seems
to be helped Along by some and
influencers in our
day. But but what happens if the the
new morality becomes the prevailing morality
and prevailing morality doesn't
mean the true morality or even the
Biblical morality as a matter of
fact, for example, the past Pastor
John and the elders have asked me to to tell you that they
have prepared a statement concerning question 8:20.
Now, that's the proposition that's coming up
legalizing recreational use of marijuana for
people 21. Oh years of age and older and so
they they have prepared a statement and you can find that statement at
the information desk in the back and also on
our website. So let me
give you a background as to how we got here tonight.
First of all, I was studying because
I thought I was going to be the presenter.
For this evening, and and I
I know a lot of things about a lot of things. I
just don't know much about this topic. So I was reading this letter
right here, which was given to me as a gift Pastor John
gives the staff a book and I asked for this
one because I knew that we would be talking about these issues. And so
I was reading the right chapter on religious liberty and
really enjoying it's a great read
how many of you don't have a copy of the
resources lists. If you don't they're in
the back and there's going to there's plenty but I was
reading from Bruce ashford's book
Letters to an American
Christian and I thought you know, why don't I
just contact this guy if he'd be available to come and I don't
have thoughts like that, but I thought because of video conferencing maybe
we could we could arrange something and so
I sent him an email and by the way,
It seems to me that the the greater influence and
the greater number of letters. You
have behind your name the less likely you
are to return an anonymous email and guess what
he returns my email. He says I would
be glad to do that. And so the guy who wrote the
book in fact, he's written a number of different books our staff
went through together as a staff the gospel
of our King, which is also written by Dr. Ashford.
So that's how
we got to this this video conferencing tonight.
And so I will be interviewing Dr. Bruce
Ashford. He's an author a speaker a
columnist and a speech writer.
He's author or co-authored six different trade
books and three different academic books. This is
one of the academic books Pastor. Did you know that your staff studies
academic work?
but
So whoo, I got a whoo. I like
them. So he has a recently he
is so
well-documented in
his academic achievements currently. He is
a fellow in the public Theology of the
Kirby Lang Institute for Christian ethics. If you
don't know what that is, that's like an academic Collective Collective of
Mines that help represent help represent
us academically in the culture and
he's a participant in the Doles koloquium of
The Institute of Religion and public life. He's a
trustee at The Institute for religion and democracy. He
writes a personal blog that discusses politics and
public life and he includes topics like
marriage and family and work and Leisure and culture and
education and church and Mission.
And you can find his blog called Christianity for
the common good at Bruce ashford.net. And
so I wanted to I try
to find a statement that that characterizes his
heart and his mind and he writes on
his website. My conviction is that
that Jesus is Lord. And for that
reason we should be thoughtful and intentional about
how our belief in him should shape
our lives. And so I've been
worrying about this for a long time. I'm going to
say let's welcome Dr. Bruce Ashford and then he's gonna appear behind
us on the screen you believe that
You don't either.
My wife said yes, so ladies and
Gentlemen. Let's welcome to Henderson Hills Baptist Church via teleconferencing,
Dr. Bruce Ashford.
No way. It'll work.
Fantastic. Well, listen, we would we
need to get to know you better Dr. Ashford. And so
tell us a little bit about yourself. Don't tell them. This is
the first time we've actually met faced to screen. But
anyway, tell us about yourself and and
tell us how you believe God has prepared you
to address the subject of religious freedom today.
Thank you so much for allowing me
to be yes. So about myself
of North Carolina. I hope that's not
enough against it.
Just during basketball season.
Yeah, just
Yeah, and don't listen
and attended
to go into politics or law.
Or quoting the ministry and I ended up service missionary
for two years instead of Malaysia with
Russia.
situation corner of Russia that was predominantly
Muslim
and and came back to the States
was ahead of the vicious Department of Southeast
Seminary about almost six right years.
And then ended up teaching this one
called.
He's turned in public theology is really the interface
of Christian Paul with public law.
The kind of things we deal with local realm
and so that's been my heartbeat.
on the matter religious liberty
I was born in 1974. Maybe there
are those of you who are at least my age who are
watching right now are a little bit older.
and I grew up during the during the Cold War and
you know, my parents received this newsletter in
the mail four times a year called The Prisoner bulletin and
it was stories from the front line and the Soviet Union. It
was about pastors and Christians who had been putting concentration
camps being tortured. Sometimes
kill the sake of the Gospel.
In other words, there was no religious liberty in the Soviet Union
and we would pray for them.
And if you had told me then
35 40 years ago
here in the United States
We would have a large number of people.
Who don't care about religious liberty?
And then an equally large number of people who are dead set against it.
I wouldn't believe.
But that's the case today. I mean our political scene in
the United States is something like the combination of
football game a carnival and a Hollywood movie, but
it's crazy.
And one of the most contested issues is religious
liberty and I'm very grateful that you asked me
to come and talk about it a little bit. It's subject which I'm which
I'm very passionate and I think that is very important.
Real quick, Dr. Ashford. Tell us a little bit about your
role at Southeastern when you were there.
People here may not know what southeastern is. So tell us
what that is.
Yeah, Southeastern Baptist Theological Seminary
It's one of the world's largest seminaries and about
5,000 students wonderful list institution. That's always
Theology and Theology and velocity there
and serve as the Director of
commission Center for a while and then the college and then
he backley and then about two and a half years ago.
I moved to become a
fellow in public theology every language University.
Also, tell us a little bit about your time in cancer, Russia
and what you learned about religious liberty while
you were there.
Yes, I lived in the Republic of Patrick Star Russia
has republics the
United States has stage Russian has Republicans. So Republican
similar to say I lived in the Republican Pakistan
one of two Muslim republics in Russia. They used
to be three till she broke away.
And so when I moved there it was on it was
a political hotspot people thought that Tucker slam
was going to try to pull away from Russia the
way chechnya had
It's about 50% Muslim
maybe 25% atheists and
25% of historic about his Christian.
And there still wasn't religious liberty even after the fall
of the Soviet Union. It was against the law for me to share the
gospel. And so when I was there I was harassed.
And there was kind of an air suspicion about me because I was
known as a religious guy.
And it's a wonderful learning experience for me.
I mean, it was freezing.
40 below zero comes in the winner
You can take a couple of Hot Coffee Starbucks coffee.
Pour it off of a third floor balcony and nothing
would hit the ground but ice chips involving grounds. Mmm those
cold. It was
costly different like to go to
The Banya which is a kind of a sauna and with each
other with Birch branches. Oh God.
And the delicious food there, but more than anything else everyone I
shared the gospel with.
And almost zero awareness
the gospel or any of the scrapbooks.
Because religious liberty had been so shuttled.
And the church had been so persecuted and imprisoned.
There's basically no gospel witness left.
And there are nation that we work hard to make
sure that that's not the case. We're not anywhere close to being
and that's your situation right now, but we
are headed in a bad Direction which many
people would like to shut a religious liberty.
So in an email exchange we discussed very
briefly the document called peaceful
coexistence and my research
says that it may have started as a
Marxist document, but but recently has been at
kind of adopted by our own government and explain
to us about this document peaceful coexistence and how
it stands in opposition to our constitution.
Yeah, so I'll just say if there are any of you there an audience
who have low blood pressure. I recommend reading this
essay completely blood pressure fix it
right just talking was published
I think and I don't know 2016 15 16 some
time along there. It was published funding United
States Commission on civil rights.
And you would think that United States Commission on civil rights?
Would be happy about religious liberty.
As a right. It's a Tron in the First Amendment to our constitution.
but instead
a majority of the people in the United States Commission on
civil rights argued in this paper that we should
Elevate non-discrimination laws above
religious liberty basically sexual preference
and gender identity non-discrimination
law above religious liberty.
So that the people speak out of their religious convictions?
In a matter that offends the transgender agenda.
Or the lgbtqia plus
agenda.
Then religious liberty loses non-discrimination went
wins. So you can find this document on
the internet our recommend you take a look at it read it
and you're gonna get a picture of what we're dealing with here
at the US. So it prioritize not discrimination laws about
religious liberty. The second thing it does.
It is salts religious Believers. All right, the chairman
of the United States Commission on civil rights. The
name is Martin Castro Vegas bidding last name. So
what he said something very similar to what Adel Castro
would say, here's what he said.
It's in the phrases religious liberty.
and religious freedom
will stand for nothing except as hypocrisy.
So long as they remain codewords for discrimination intolerance.
racism sexism
homophobia
islamophobia
Christian Supremacy or any other form of
entire lives
So the president of the United States Commission on civil
rights, Spartan Castro?
Believes in religious liberty is a code word.
for hypocrisy
bigotry and hatred
and so it smears and insults religious Believers
second thing that it does.
Third thing who doesn't misunderstands religion and
this is a very important point.
There are a lot of people in the United States many on
the left and some on the right. For example Wall Street,
right?
Who really don't give a flip about religion
they don't think it seriously.
and that if you religion the way we would you
a code or some
form of outer
something that people like to put on and dress up with
but they can easily take it off and there will be any consequences.
And that's what they want us to do. They want us to put our religious clothing on
when we go to church.
Or when we're at home.
But we're going to the Public Square and we talk about public issues.
You better take that note off believe it at the
door.
That's your view of religion religion is a superficial add-on
to life.
And a negative superficial add-on at that.
So what they want to do is they want to privatize religion.
And this brings up another document you'll hope it's okay. If
I bring up one more thing the Uber Excel
May Hodges same-sex marriage ruling.
And in that ruling the descending opinions
justices Roberts Thomas Toledo warned.
That that really had serious repercussions for
the person Amendment right to freedom
to create exercise of religion. Let me read you
a couple of things are pretty important justices said 50 cents
any opinions Chief Justice John Robinson.
the majority in this opinion
graciously Bank stations here graciously suggest
that religious Believers may continue to advocate.
and teach
their views of Mayor
the first amendment power
unlike them guarantees the freedom to
exercise religion.
The point he's making here.
Is the Supreme Court majority of that time?
Just like the United States mission on civil rights wants to
privatize religion.
And want, you know, we can wear your religious floating if
you want to at church and at home
in private my spaces.
But you better take that stuff off and leave it when you come to
Public Square.
And then just Robert says yes, unfortunately people of faith
can take no comfort in the treatment they received from
the majority today.
I also want to read something that Justice deleted
said that's the similarly to.
He said I assume that those who cling to Old beliefs.
Will be able to whisper their thoughts.
in the recesses of their homes
but if they repeat those views in public
They will risk being labeled as bigots.
and treated as such
by governments
employers and schools
by imposing its own view on the entire country majority facilitates
from marginalization of the
many Americans that additional ideas.
So this I mean these two documents there's so
much more evidence out there. I mean you've got Google
You watch the news. You understand that that's what we
deal with.
We're not just illness problem with with sometimes with
springboard. We're not just dealing with the problem in
the United States fish on civil rights. We're dealing with
major corporations in the United States who are
weaponized against Christian faith.
And I can tell you this we can't count on Wall Street
Wall Street left and many times the Wall
Street, right?
To have our concerns in mind.
When they pour money and whoever it
is, they want to be put on the ballot.
So Dr. Ashford, what
would you say in juxtaposition to this peaceful
coexistence document explained to
us briefly and concisely if
you will, what is the first amendment and why is
it so important for for the United
States?
Yes, because the First Amendment to the United States Constitution speaks to
a number of Rights including religious liberty.
Let me read.
Word for word here. It says Congress shall make no law.
respecting an establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof.
And this is very well put.
Book it says on the one hand.
Religion shouldn't be Force top down on anybody.
Congress shouldn't make a law.
Instituting Christianity is the official religion of the land in
order to be assisted in the United States. You have to be a
member of a Christian church or anything like that.
another hand
religion shouldn't be restricted top down.
So it shouldn't be Force Tottenham should be
forced to worship top down.
not should we be forced not to worship and not to exercise
our religion and
Now this free exercise of religion is extremely irritating
to a lot of our fellow citizens.
They would be fine with religious liberty.
If it was just that we had the right to teach what we
want to teach in our churches in our children at home.
That many of them will be okay with that.
What they are not okay with it's the free exercise
of religion.
Because listen to the Bible teaches when the Bible talks about religion.
It uses the word heart.
But we use the word heart over 800 times
to refer to religion.
And the Bible talks about the heart. Of course, it's not talking about the
party of vascular unit of pumps blood through
our body. It's referring to the Deep deepest interboast
recesses of the cell the central
organizer Community excesses.
And the Bible teaches that every human being is religious.
All of us in worshipers. We are the
worst of the god of Jesus Christ.
Or Allah Muhammad.
Or we were success or money or power.
The Bible's point is this that every human being absolutes is
something in life. We ascribe ultimately to
sign.
Sex for money or power for Jesus or whatever it is.
And whatever we prescribe ultimately to whatever is
number one for us functions that our God.
So someone could either worship the god of Jesus Christ so they can
work with counterfeit God. What are the other but everybody worships?
and the Bible also says that that
the issues of life flow from the heart
what that means is that once the human being has made
a decision to absolutize something in their life.
Once it holds the number one position sits on
the throne of the heart.
It absolutely will affect.
The way we act when we speak.
our dispositions and our attitudes
and so our Christianity should naturally
overflow into the
rest of our life.
And so if we don't have free exercise of religion.
We don't have freedom of religion at all.
So you would say that the US
Constitution stands in perfect opposition
to the peaceful coexistence Doctrine coming
from the Civil Rights chair. What
do you what would you say the
Christian faith has to say about religious
liberty.
Yeah, you know, I'll start by saying I think the Christian faith
teaches something that God's ideal.
Is something very much like what we see in the First Amendment
to the United States Constitution that people should and
we people should be free to align their lives
of their conditions and to do so freely.
openly and without fear
so if we were to go through different teachings in the Bible.
Excuse me. I'm of an advanced age now in the
minority since I've got to put my reading glasses on. Thank you.
Look good in those sir. I've been nervous Panic every
time I get ready to stand up and teach. So
I forgot my reading glasses. I'm gonna mess.
So the first thing we've mentioned is that in the Bible. No, we're
we see God coercing religion.
It doesn't he doesn't.
Doesn't want to coerce us.
And so first first thing first thing about the second
is that God created us and His Image and likeness.
And part of being created in His image and likeness is
that we have freedoms to choose.
and to act
and to create and to think I mean a great freedom to
fashion alive
in a way that we choose as long as it does to bring harm to other people.
And and so this is has been known about the
circles as freedom of conscience. And that's a good way to put it God's given
us freedom of conscience.
The third thing to note is that the Bible teaches
us of the Gospel is freely given and freely receive.
Amidst the nature of the Gospel right that God freely sent
his son.
First Corinthians, you know Paul says to the Corinthians,
you know, or wherever you want to whatever statement in
the Bible want to go through First
Corinthians. 1535 is a good one.
That God freely gave his son.
to die behalf of our sins
to be buried
and to rise from the dead.
To set us free from the consequences of our sins and his resurrection
from the dead is also down women and he's going
to return one day to set the world to rise.
This gospel was freely given by God and and we
freely receive it. We can accept it or we
can reject that's the nature of True Religion.
And so we don't want to set up a situation in the United States
legally.
You know that that goes against that.
the last thing that I would imagine
Is this look?
Nobody can actually take away.
Our religious liberty completely.
the Christians and the Soviet Union
Who were born from their homes?
put in concentration camps
Where they died after six or nine months or a
year?
Sometimes killed by Iron squads.
the Christians in different areas of North Africa in
the Middle East to experience severe persecution
the early Christians
and church history
the anabaptists our corvairs
balances argue buyers an example. He's a young Theologian
is I think he's in his early 30s when he's burned
alive at the state.
and poor gunpowder induced beer
when I'm on fire and burn it from the base down.
These men and women didn't have their religious liberty taken
away.
They were still free to exercise their religion. They just
had to be ready to accept the consequences.
And so I think one of the things that we learned from church
history and from our brothers and sisters around the world.
Is that if we do find ourselves in a situation where our
religious liberty is restricted in some way or punished, but
it that way.
Then God's call upon us as to exercise our religion
and be willing to face the consequences.
That's a top feel for America's swallow.
Because we've always come from a position of strength where
we had freedom.
And we're slowly beginning to lose that freedom of waste.
So if it if it appears as
that, the societal trend is turning
away from religious liberty. What how did
that happen? What what did we do to allow
that to happen? And what can we do to
kind of stem that tide? Is there anything?
Is the big question you throw fastballs, you know that we get
you one night so stand at the
plate and take your medicine.
So there's geometry is
that way out of 7 or 2008
it was a brilliant.
eccentric genius
it was hired or fully tenured faculty member
at 23 years old at University, Pennsylvania.
Most college students today are a year number seven
of college when they're 24 and haven't
quite radicated yet. This guy was and he started
out on the left. He was a darling of the left. He was
on all the big talk shows and the you know, the yes the
60s and 70s.
And then he disappeared for about 25 years.
went underground
any resurfaced toward the end of his life
at the turn of the century.
And published a Trilogy called The Sacred order
social order trilogy.
And he had become quite conservative in the meantime.
And in this book when he argues is he already said the
United States or the West in general but especially
the United States has been in the middle of it historically unprecedented
at its campus severed or from
social worker now, that's that's fancy language.
Scholars people and Academia
feel like they have to make up words and phrases right makes it important
and
And said, he was important obviously.
But that what he means by safer to order is a
religious and moral ordering.
That every society every civilization history has
had some sort of religious moral ordering.
And he said that the cultural Elite in the United States
I wanted to sever.
Social order which is our cultural institutions
in our society.
to separate
from our religious moral ordering so that society and
culture float on their own now being rooted
in the day of Christian role.
and
we found this offensive and he found it greatly destructive.
to our culture
He called our cultural lead
to officer class.
Because I like to order a surround.
Because I think they know best.
And they think that society would be better off without.
What brings is that? They've been quite successful.
but that there's hope
and when he says that there's hope we should listen to it.
Because he taught one of the most liberal institutions in
the United States of America and all of his friends are people to
the far far left.
Who don't care about religious liberty or are opposed
to?
And he said that there's hope of pause has already
cracks in the foundation. He said that they're
already is a bit of a panic.
among opponents of the Christian faith
because they're beginning to taste the consequences of the
red rejection of the basic moral order
of articulated by Judaism and Christianity.
And he ends his book.
Um first book is called my life
among the death.
And death works by the way, what he argues is.
Is it in a culture where we have gotten rid of did you know
Christian world you?
That the cultural products the things we produce the
music and the movies and the artwork
and Etc. He said they become death. Wor.
Ries and instead of breathing life into society they bring
that okay.
and at the end of this book
He said that the world awaits of people.
And I'm gonna name that.
the Christian church
and specifically Anderson Hills
tonight
the world awaits of people who can recover the Friday beauty
of the Thou shalt and the Thou shalt not
think about that for a moment.
Say that out and now shall not he has gonna say
say that again and elaborate for us make
us understand that.
Yes, and the thriving beauty of the Thou shalt and
the Thou shalt not.
So Thou shalt enough shalt not the first of the moral
order what we should things that we should do and things that we shouldn't do
and God has played those out for us in Scripture.
And reset there's a frightening Beauty to it.
It's beautiful because when Society lives by
these rules, there's order.
And the katana have awarded that causes human beings to
flourish.
But it's also product.
for people who want to be their own God
because it reminds them.
That they're not Young.
And so recent is that the world awaits of
people and our challenge not I think the challenge that
God gives us.
Is for us to take ownership of that that we are.
and so reef reef is the first intellectual I want
I want to point to
the second intellectual
he sees there are some little lectures for Good Guys.
And who teach at some of the big universities they're the second
electron, which is many Charles Taylor.
Now, it's not the same God with Chuck Taylor tennis shoes. All
right. Thank you.
different guy
and Charles Taylor wrote an enormous
book. I mean, he's huge. It's size of a cinder block. It's called
a secular age. I don't recommend that you read it. If you
do buy and try to read it, I'd definitely I recommend
that you're not reading at night when you're getting ready to go to bed because
I'm afraid to tell it, you know start reading
it. You'll fall asleep that sense get depression. Yeah.
and I'm ready for you and
I'll kind of describe what he says system and at the
beginning, you know, a lot of the book he's saying something similar to
read.
And then it and add something to it. But but it
says, you know Christianity has been displaced from
the default position.
So when he says that we live in a secular age. He doesn't mean
we live in an age for their hardly any religious believers.
That's not true.
But he says we live in a secular age doesn't mean that
most people.
It's not true.
What he means is that.
Christianity has been displaced from the default position.
And now it's just one among does
so philosophies will use an ideology.
And it will still lasting.
Years, they aren't using he also gives a really good
view into the mindset of secular progressives.
He says listen.
Secular progressives who?
Want to undermine the Christian thing?
And overthrow it.
That's very confident what they believe.
This is a matter of fact their fragilized. So
you made a horror. I told you like to
make work.
Fragilize it'd be important. Let's get
their own work. But so he says
that
people in a secular west across pressure and fragilized
All right. Let's take each of those words.
One at a time.
cross pressure
What are you saying is we have cross-pressions. We've
got a pressure coming from one side and pressure coming from
Another Side.
From one side we have this social pressure.
to capitulate
the disown the Christian faith to get rid of the Christian
teaching on gender and sexuality specific.
Most of the hot and buff issues to
American politics have been together.
That just that's a fact.
So there's a pressure get rid of Christianity.
So we can do and say what we want with regarded gender
insects and other things.
This is pressure not to believe that bigoted hateful
ignorant stuff.
But there's a cross pressure Taylor status.
But if you read your Bible.
and if you pay attention to the world around
you'll know that God instructed the
world at such a way that it testifies existence.
The Taylor points that out.
He calls it signals at transcendent.
That's another phrase that was made up by differences
the element. It's also important.
obviously
a signals of transcendence that there are things all around
us like a sunset.
of the sunrise
or I mean you name it
the massive beauty of this world. It's ordering its
regularity.
The law cause and effective do bad things
that is going to happen in return when you do good things good
things tend to happen return.
all of these features of the universe being in the existence of
a god
and Taylor says that many of the people who seemed so
firmly opposed and adamantly opposed the Christian faith
are actually quite fragile fragilized.
by this cross pressure
and so refunds Taylor both give us some encouragement.
Reef said
the world awaits of people
and that's God's people. That's true.
and Taylor says
the people we'd like to fix
there may be a lot of Bluster.
and a lot of vitriol
But deep down meaning in fragile in
their beliefs. The last thing Taylor says
is something I find fasting.
Makes up another praise.
He says that the United States is characterized by
an extraordinary moral inarticulous.
And here's how explains it.
Says on the one hand.
People in the United States have seen incredible.
ideals
We're going to abolish poverty program.
So that there's equal income for everyone on the globe.
you know, we're gonna get rid of it justice, we're gonna
usher in you know, we're gonna have political revolutions
that
give us kind of a Utopia episode. So we
have these really high deals. Yes.
but the Army is
we have nothing to fund those ideals. We have
no way of we have nothing to point where ideas
come from except around. Yes.
We've got rid of the idea that there's a God the hundred bird
age like this.
Who would act and make it happen?
We've gotten rid. I mean listen.
If there's a moral law.
There has to be a law given.
But they insist that there's no law Giver.
So now that could be no more alone.
All there is more opinion.
And so what Taylor points out is that we live in this country was
for me love decided. There's no longer.
And now they're realizing that means there's no more a law.
All there is a plural opinions.
And when all there is is only thing that's
left to do is to shout each other down.
Which is a pretty good description probably if you're basically electrons,
you know.
I mean, that's what happens when you get you know, that email from Uncle Earl.
It's like in all half expectations. Just want
to see local girls all caps lock it is
exclamation mark he disabled it would be able to send an email
and
Were just business look we're in a tough spot that we've got brief,
and we've got Taylor.
Now the third intellectual.
Is a didn't even tell local christian.
Very similar to us maybe throw
through.
And he's written on a concept called expressive individualism.
and this isn't unique to him and he's written the
the world Authority book
and I'm sure he's made up some words to that. I just don't
remember as our season.
but expressive individualism says this
and when he's arguing is a secular
age.
In our secular age America expresses individualism has
become the functional religion for many or
most Americans.
including many Americans Republic Christians
expressive individualism
The point of life is feel and take.
and the way to be authentic
is to follow the desires of my heart.
That's how you you're authenticated.
and the way to be an authentic Society
is to applaud other people for following
the desires of their heart.
Now do you see the problem with that?
The problem is it besides our hearts are all completely.
Wrong and one way area.
And so that's what we've got. Our own Nation right now is we've
got a nation full of people who want to
fulfill their own desires. A lot of that is sexually
but there's other things too a lot
of its sexual.
And want Society go all them for doing it.
So this is the sort of situation Brandon. Yes,
I mean Bill your fastball group.
I've swung three times now actually the three
that's one with Taylor as long with Truman.
I hope they hit ball with one of them. All right, if I didn't
free trucks in your app. This is how we
go we are
This is why we can't have nice things.
So let's all in all of our toys
while we're
in a rough spot here in the
US and one more thing here.
I'm sorry Bill. He's here Professor. I thought
um, I'm not important that that's made up
anymore.
Here's the deal.
This change has been in the way for a long time. We can say
at least since the 60s.
Those of you have a certain age some of you were alive 60s you
saw it happen.
So we've got more than happy century.
of secularization
This is not going to be changed in the next election.
Now I know that.
People news show in America will tell you.
Every single presidential election cycle that this
is the most important presidential election cycle ever
in America history.
and I don't need to minimize presidential election Cycles,
but
there's no presidential elections. I'm going to face the
best brainer.
Can move the needle on a better correct? Sure, we're
gonna have to play the ball game.
We're gonna have to bear plate with this and do
the hard work right balls change.
for decades on it
That's what we're going to have to.
so
you mentioned that that the secular
religious social I mean the sexual
or social order sees cracks in the
foundation.
And you've also said that we can
stem the tide by playing the long game and
being the voice that God's called
us to be what does that
look like practically for a none of
us here are in a religious think
tank or professors at the Seminary but but
we do want to make a difference. And so what does that look
like? How can we make a difference?
playing the long game
Yes, so let me out the phrase to that. We need to
take the broad view and we need to play the long game.
So let's start with taking Broadview.
Thank you the wrong humase. And I think this is
going to be encouraging.
For for those of you who are out there and video lands
right now for kids video and we're there
and there's still that.
All of the things God has given you to do in life.
all of them matter to him
each of those things
God calls every Christian to a family
a church
workplace
And a community right? So we're a family member a church
member.
a worker
your work could be at home or be out of
the home. Either way. It's workplace.
And then called you be a citizen and community and the way you
fulfill those callings the way we fulfill those callings.
Does impact our society?
not just
an impacts Society on the national level
we can get
I was uncommon as the Fox News for four years you
would think that would be able not really I mean
news influence well enough, but I'm not able I mean even when
I had
You know some positions like that you would think would have
some influence of what we have that much influence. None of
us do but we do have influence of the local
level in the state level.
So when we exercise our colleagues
When we take when when we're faithful in our
workplace, for example, you might work in art Sciences
or scholarship and education politics and
economics Business and Entrepreneurship.
agriculture
Entertainment, it is sports. I
mean you name it.
That's the place where we can exercise significant influence.
By doing our work to God's glory and representing him. Well
so that when people see a Christian they respect that Christian.
That's one of the things we got to do is we've got
to live the sort of lives that are respected in the community the early
church. Did this in Rome?
And when they were persecute religious minority and
even Julius Stanford who hated
them had to say he said I forget the
exact quote at one point put out of public places. Like
I'm so tired of hearing.
That it's always the Christians to take care of the sick from the plane comes
through. I'm so tired of them setting up hospitals. I can
do what they do.
We're just as good as them are we?
In other words, he was jealous of the good things they did and what
God would like us to do.
Is to make other people jealous so to speak.
of the good lives with
so that they'll want that God.
So taking the broad view means that changing influencing
Society. Thank God.
It's not limited to the 2024 presidential election.
Which most Americans Christian are not as we think.
Being culture change comes from residential life.
But it's a significant moment. I'm not saying it's
not important experience.
But the things we do in an everyday basis.
All of those things are important.
slain elongate this means
We've got to be invisible Long Haul and the warning
that I know that I've always tried to give my students
is.
Don't sell your soul.
To get a short-term political think free of whatever sort it
is.
just
are influence
for Christ
Is something that stretches over the entirety of our lifetime?
I'm not over the next year or the next two and a
given presidential election site. So
let's not.
For example, behave better the election site.
And show ourselves and act out in a bad
ways.
Because we feel like I'm sure for some
reason that will be good but not the
meaning great people we disagree with assembly line
at Christian career after you hear the wall.
And then the other thing I would mention is.
Just encourage you all here. There are legal.
firms like Alliance, depending freedom
first celebrity in Texas
who are fighting in Arabic hat on matters of religious liberty
that is religious liberty freedom of speech other
rights that we've got. And so
there's legal reasons recourse against Martin Castro
is proud.
We also happy for us to civil disobedience.
If and when we are told we can't speak
our mind on again issue.
Even when we are told of not exercise our faith and
given way.
We do have the ability to dissipate engage
in Civil Disobedience.
I think we should say civil disability really
matters.
Or else we likely I'd love.
But that's a recourse called future we need it.
And then finally on the you know
playing office of this. Yes, we can just take
a page out of the Playbook of the person's future.
the majority of restaurants historically
outside of the medieval
Christian West
Morty majority of Christians historically a majority of Christians
around the globe today lived in places where their religious
Liberties is punished.
Their their punished severely besides their religion.
We're kind of the exception.
And so, you know if the news it's Ronald.
if we received some punishments for acting
on our beliefs
then
God will walk with us through the fire.
so
let me ask you a couple of questions.
Is it possible?
I want to be careful when I say this and you
may figure out why as I ask it. Is it possible to
win a short-term political victory?
and lose
in the long game
Can you give me an example?
I don't have an example that I'm willing to give okay?
would say
one of the things
the founding fathers
never envisioned the United States in which there
were two major political parties.
heavenly
That was not their vision.
It might surprise you because it's the only thing you've known.
But what happens when you have two major political parties?
Isn't their invented each other.
They depend on each other.
There's only one person to demonize.
We could focus all of our efforts we can toss elections back
and forth we each other.
and whoever we
Nominate, they're gonna have to look for him.
and there's gonna come a time when we as, you know,
wouldn't even go Christians are going to have to say
to a given party
We're not going to vote for whatever head you can do on
hand to us on a planet.
Probably I'll be my guest.
another
way that we can lose. I mean, I think we we feel under such
fresh or to make our point and a short
term, you know, short-term issue like that. Maybe it's an election or
a contested issue that we're willing
to behave badly hmm to speak
in ways or Unbecoming of the Christian faith.
To degrade other people we give
ourselves a right to judge other people's bars.
And the things that the Bible never gets us permission to
do.
um
that answer is exactly what
I was hoping to hear because I see out of
frustration and out of fear Christians responding in
manners that are not very Christian.
You know Jesus when he spoke.
He spoke some hard Cruise man, when he said some things yeah
people like a bag of hammers. He didn't
pull his punch this video great.
You know when he spoke he spoke with this powerful combination of
Truth and Grace by truth. I
mean that he spoke the truth about reality.
Didn't hold it back.
and by grace
I mean that he spoke it in such a way that he wasn't
decimating the person.
And condemning the person.
so
like
when we the political REM and we speak truth without Grace.
or political bullies
that doesn't honor God.
like we speak truth about Grace is when we
don't speak as somebody who
get them for the grace of God should be condemned.
You know we speak in a different manner from a perch from a moral
merge with condescension and and
with a kind of a condemning wrath or other people.
And that's political bullying and that we shouldn't be characterized
by that.
But then another had people speak when they
speak then got raised but not true.
It's all graciousness.
But they're gonna pull the punches and not tell the truth our praying
to say the Bible says in a given issue.
And their political went for non-energies.
So we don't want to be political bullies.
Jerks on the one hand. We don't want to be political Winston on
the enemies on the other hand.
We want to exhibit that Jesus that powerful
Jesus like combination of Truth and Grace.
amen
So I want to ask one more question before we do that. I'd like to summarize some of the things
that I've heard so that if I'm wrong you can you can
You can correct me first and foremost. We have the privilege of
voting. So we take the Holy Spirit into the
voting booth with us. And then the secondly
We Can Make a Difference by just praying
and living out our faith where
God has called us to live whether that's our home
or our work or our church or neighborhood wherever
God has called us to make a difference for him and number
three we can we can
support those who are illegal that
support legal recourse like the
alliance defending freedom.
We don't have to worry yet about Civil Disobedience, but
that's an option if we ever have to I'm not
excited about that. But but I do trust that the
Lord.
The Lord's plans will prevail and and he
has used Christians in much more difficult circumstances in
a mighty way.
And he will use us as well. So the last question I
want to pull back a little bit from the political Arena and
just talk about what does it mean to have to Be
an Effective Christian witness in the secular age. How
can we how can we be that effective Christian Witnesses? Just
is that our testimony? What does that
look like?
Yeah, you know I've listed four things here and they
all start with an alarm.
I haven't been at work. I'm not actually answer this
question. So we mentioned four things we can
do to give powerful witness from
position of cultural weakness. In other
words. We find our stuff for the minority. How can we still get powerful witness
it first thing we need to do I would
say is to resent her God.
Or reintroduce God to the Public
Square.
God has already been introduced.
To lots of Americans and he's been
introduced to them by MSNBC.
and by CNN
and my box and by
Muslims of my Buddhists and by seculars, I mean
they put lots of things about God.
But they probably actually haven't met the god
that we know we've got to find some way to reintroduce
him to the public imagination.
So they're imagining God and thinking of him the
way he actually is.
Rather than dispute or distorted version. They might have to see
so what are some ways we can do that recenter God.
One of the things we can do is we can make sure that the
Bible's Narrative of the world.
Is our Master Mary?
That's where the world is what frames everything else for us
that it's not the Fox News narrative famous MSNBC
narrative or the CNN area.
Now those people know what's funny. I have a
favorite among those three. It's not MSNBC.
But what I'm saying is the bottles Narrative of
the world that is the master narrity and when
any of our favorite people news networks or political funds
or political parties or whatever Department in the Bible says the
world
we stay within the Bible started the world and it's our
Master friend of reality.
Um a second thing is that we got to find
ways of
articulating to people or showing people
that our God
is The One and Only God the true God and that
when we the god of Jesus Christ is the
only one who can follow through on his promise.
That when you elevate sexual pleasure or
financial gain or power.
Or the approval of other people or any
of these other things to the ultimate level
in your life.
And you put them on the throne.
those things can't promise to sell they they can't deliver on the
salvation of
and when we as a country corporately elevates
says
or money or power
and we make it ultimate.
Then he can't deliver for our country when it costs
and instead hurts us to breaks us.
So we've got to find a way that we can to reset
for God put him back to the center and look
see really is.
The second thing is equally important.
If we have if we're going to reset for God we're going to have to decent
for the self.
And what does it mean to decenter the self it means that?
How do you descent itself?
One of the ways we decent for ourselves as Christians is so
that God can take Center Stage instead
of us taking Center Stage is is
for Christians to be known as the people who seek the good of the
whole city as it says in Jeremiah 29 chapter
29 verse 57. God told me Israel
to see the good of the city.
He says the same thing to his church today is to seek
the good of our entire nation. So we don't want to be seen as
kind of people who only webinarize politically to
get rights for Christians.
We want to be seen as the kind of people.
Who want to push for a political agenda in our country that serves everybody
well?
For us to be the kind of people that genuine concern for the
economically disadvantage who had genuine concern or
victims of crops.
Or whatever the issues we think
we want to be seen as good built. We want to
be good will be.
And seek the good of our whole extent.
The second way to decenter the self is this
combination of proof of Grace?
if we can refuse to be political bullies and
jurors
Even when our political leaders are releasing jerks.
If we can speak with truth and Grace the
way Jesus did.
And followed Jesus instead of a favorite political leader.
That's a way of decent bring the self. It's way
engage in politics. It's not egocentric.
narcissistic vitriolic
Etc
So there is a way to this doesn't mean to
be a wimp in the Public Square. You can be strong. Jesus was strong.
The strongest, you know, the strongest vendors ever lived.
That we can speak through the power.
And we can stick to our governments and we could not budge.
and we can also do it our
retaining a Christian
so we want to receptor.
on a decent of the cell
Actually all about points just right number
three
we want to reframe.
issues
I mean by that is this.
And you've got these hot political places in the United States, right? And
you've got standard problem points of publicans
issues standing standard talking points Democrats.
You know particularly.
And even when you align a lot more with one party
than you do with the other and you align with them on the
issue.
As a Christian you might address that issue in a
different manner.
So that when you're speaking to that it should even if you come to
the same conclusion as let's say a generic Republic somewhere.
Or a generic Republican politically
the function does he never come
into the same conclusion that way you are particulated?
You might give a different explanation for it as a Christian drawing on
the body.
Or it might be that your tone is different.
That you actually about demeaning integrated if
you disagree with.
it's honestly most of the we just
have different solutions
and even if their Solutions on solution is
I mean horrible person who should be
even if they're behavioral moment.
You know we can still take them.
As somebody created a good place God so the wrong.
The way that doesn't agree.
So we can reframe issues and we can and then
finally.
I've got this big term Revitalize both.
That seems like a huge ass.
Like all right, Grace smart guy. How do
I Revitalize it? My name is Frank. I
probably, you know, my name is
Michelle and I'm still whatever, you know,
like we're saying earlier we take the broad.
They belonging.
What we do is we just say, this is God. I'm giving me.
This family this journey.
This place of work, it's Community to live
in I'm gonna honor you that's the facility.
and everything I do
that revitalizes
the breakdown America
a large part of it is great getting families to churches.
Those are two of the most important institutions in our
culture. They're supposed to be a war.
against bad things and athletic
But our families are great.
many of our churches
that we can strengthen our families to strengthen our churches.
We can air our places.
where if we can carry ourselves pretty well public
safer and not act down behave that
and speak well on behalf. Good ambassadors.
We are really.
And we can listen.
God works
for the work of this, baby.
He Delights.
and bringing fruit
to the season we stop and so we're faithful
we can trust that. God will do something.
Faithfully sowing seeds
the long game
and the broad view I think that's
man, we were hoping you would fix this thing tonight, but
If that's not going to happen, we just want to say thank you for coming and being a
part of what we're doing here Church. Let's show him our appreciation.
We also we just want to not only
say thank you for giving us this night. But thank you for serving the lord. So
Faithfully the way you do and representing Us
in an arena that we don't really have access to I
think yeah, I'm encouraged and I knowing that you're
you're there for us doing the hard work and the heavy lifting so
All right. Well love this is
not happened in the three weeks. We've been doing these these
topics but we have
10 minutes nine minutes left and we're not
going to take any questions from the audience because we don't
have the
Don't have the technology or the courage just the
joke about the courage. We don't
have the technology but or the courage, but anyway,
I just want to say thank you for coming and and if
and can I pray for you and for our
church as we go forward?
Let's pray. Yes.
Father thank you so much for the United
States of America and how Lord you have been able to fund
a missions globally through the middle class
here for so many years. But Lord as the cultural winds
begin to blow in a
different direction and as we begin to feel more marginalized and less
free, I pray Lord you would allow us to remember that
it is you and your power and your Sovereign way that
direct us.
The Lord let us do play the long game Lord.
Let us see the Broadway. Let us treat our
our fellow brothers and sisters
in Christ and our people in our family in a manner that people
would take notice Lord. Let us plant seeds that would bear
fruit in righteousness. So that people could see who God
is and who they're missing when they don't follow him.
What I pray for Dr. Ashford, thank you for Lord for
not only his willingness to be with us tonight. But for his faithfulness to
represent you and your word and your truth
in an arena Lord that that is
very few voices like his and I just pray Lord you would
protect him Lord speak to him through him
with power. And with that perfect balance
like Jesus had of Grace and Truth and
it is in Jesus name that we pray. Amen.
Amen. All right. Well, thank you, Dr.
Ashford and